[Music]
it's a news overload
i keep getting this video from this dude
yeah
that people are sending me that's like
yo man
if you get this video somebody care
about you
you should send this video out this one
right here
yeah hey listen man i'm gonna keep this
short
and sweet if you watching this right now
is because somebody five million of you
you want to see you win damn
period five minutes never heard of them
and i'm telling people now like man [ __ ]
this [ __ ] man if you care about me
you make a video for me let me send me
a video of another [ __ ] that i don't
know this
this dude's strength i don't know this
dude never heard of him
this might respect you somebody's
checking up on your mental health
right now god goddess god is the
greatest
we the best no wait
wait who's the best him or god
he said god is the greatest we the best
well the best and the greatest are two
different things right
i think they're synonymous man no
they say muhammad ali's the greatest
boxer is really not too many people in
that category
they'll say like floyd mayweather is the
best yeah
but muhammad ali is the greatest that's
two different
that's two different things like they
say some people say like it's people
with better stats than jordan but jordan
is
the greatest greatest yeah no i agree i
agree like best you can be the best
at the time i feel like that's more of a
temporary thing like he's the best right
now
but the greatest that means like he he's
in the hall of fame
like he's transferring the best best
sounds like something
that you get at a state fair
[Laughter]
well think about hip-hop though like you
could say that you know like hands-down
insert name here like locksmith or
somebody's the is the is the best
lyricist but he was never in a
discussion as the greatest
like the greatest gotta like have you
gotta have club bangers
you gotta have songs girls you gotta
have some
songs dudes like to smoke you gotta be
able to do everything really well
so does everyone agree does anyone have
an argument for that maybe the best
could be the greatest i hear yeah yeah
this is
you know i was i was wrong i just
started thinking about
dj khaled saying we're the best over and
over
yeah that makes me believe it less yes
that's the nail in the coffin right
there yeah i was like greater is better
than best yeah
that on that we the greatest it's a news
overload media